my question then is we've had all this
reporting stacked up we are now
operating to the assumption this is true
they knew they lied the world that the
organization lied that this may have
according to Fox News was a breach an
accidental breach what do we do some
people on Twitter have said wipe all of
them the US debt to China that's it boom
I don't know you anymore bro you caused
this problem you cost me money I'm not
paying you back I mean see that that's
where we get into the big hearty
reminder that they make all of our
medicines they make everything still for
us we rely on them people are talking
about old people dying it's like okay
cut China off and then all of those
people that need their blood thinner
medicine or insulin I mean I could go on
you know it all come by demand see
everything from China right now so it's
like we can't do you that Frazee you
know Obama the Obama administration
wanted more US jobs to go to China
really more the idea was that it would
force China to like it would force our
economies to intertwine and that would
prevent China from overtaking us that
was their idea
okay so send more American jobs over to
China that's called the trans-pacific
partnership truck shut it down I'm like
what day one really the first thing he
does wasn't really but like actually it
might have been well that had been
bothering him I think that totally but
Bernie Bernie - the same thing that the
TPP it would have it would have sent
hundreds of thousands of jobs over to
China yeah we need those jobs so the
idea they had whatwhat the way it the
way they explained it is it would make
them dependent upon us for these jobs
you know and a lot of people have
tweeted at me like because we've we've
talked about this before and they say
you know it wouldn't work because
America has a minimum wage and then we
you know you couldn't make products as
cheap and it's like you know what the
problem with this is people buy cheap
things and they break and then they go
buy more because there's more
why don't let's go back to making
quality stuff that is more expensive but
it lasts forever you know and you can
miss it this is the craziest thing
wealth inequality all these lefties are
complaining about
yeah it's driven by open borders that's
why I understand it's an impossible
political situation these people have
put themselves in you know and that's
why you'll never see me supporting it
listen if you have a mate a billionaire
in the United States hmm and he says I'm
gonna make socks for people to put on
their feet you know why cuz Americans
need things on their feet everybody does
so then he goes and sends all the
factories to China the Americans then go
to the store and say one pair of socks
please pay the ten bucks that ten
dollars goes to China and that a portion
of it goes to the billionaire or I
should say it goes to the billionaire
then he cuts he gives his cut to the to
the factories the wealth inequality has
been being driven by the fact that the
American worker has been removed from
the equation yeah
the American worker gives their money
away for the product gets nothing in
return and the billionaires make cash
and the Chinese laborers make the money
exactly it's driving wealth inequality
so you this is why Bernie Sanders and
Donald Trump had very similar similar
policies was very populist nationalist
Pro America Bernie made the mistake of
chasing after these people who don't
believe in anything yeah it's it's crazy
there was I think I saw this tweet was
like cardi B was was doing an interview
with Bernie Sanders had said something
lies she said that open borders is
capitalist that I saw that tweet I don't
know if it's true but it is even Bernie
Sanders said this back in 2015 open
borders is a coke brothers proposal
right wing proposal for cheap labor yeah
oh oh oh you want to bring factories
back to America well we're gonna need
cheap labor so we can still make the
profit that we've been used to and
that's why they want illegal immigrants
exactly and like stop learning about
product and let's make like a make
America strong and bring you know bring
that middle ground back to the American
citizens if so this is why I think it's
interesting to talk about the
disappearing middle class right yeah
yeah because you've sent it overseas
exactly
it's crazy but what's really fascinating
is that you can have in 2016 a Donald
Trump and a Bernie Sanders saying the
same things you know that there's leaked
audio of Donald Trump's and back in the
day saying like Bernie is the one I'm
really worried about because he's a
trade guy and trades my thing hmm
yeah so I said I think I think the
reason why the Democratic establishment
really really hates Bernie is that as
much as he
flip flopped and started bending the
knee to them yeah he does represent an
end of this international where they
call like an neoliberal economic order
or whatever something like that where
it's like we're gonna keep expanding
free trade send more jobs overseas
that's an extraction of our economy and
eventually it collapses you end up with
exactly what we're seeing now you know
Silicon Valley being a really great
example Silicon Valley's all these
billionaires meanwhile down at the first
floor human waste all over the streets
homelessness drug abuse you know that
even the police who live who are working
in San Fran can't afford to live there
you know and you know where the labor is
done for these these these tech firms
know don't
that's Eastern Europe of course and
because it's it's cheap it's really
cheap and easy to do profit profit and
greed well it's it's it's interesting
it's it's it's capitalist it's not
left-wing I don't understand why these
like dude remember we were saying
yesterday when I said people on the Left
are not being on the Left doesn't mean
you have some you're mentally deficient
right but people are mentally deficient
will be attracted to the left right
that's kinda far left I mean and I think
it's because they give you
pie-in-the-sky solutions they give you
they tell you that they're gonna give
you rainbows and candy canes and then
people think I want that whereas a
mature adult is gonna say I don't
believe you you know that's too good to
be true right so what would you really
want well what you end up getting are
you know the democratic socialists of
America voted at there it was like in
September I think for open borders how
did you convince all of these lefties
who are supposed to be fighting for
labour yeah to support one of the most
capitalistic yeah like its systems ever
yeah trying to protect labor that's
gonna ruin labor totally in America yep
factories gone but the you know it is no
it's not gone your jobs are gone you're
right they go to the the people that
aren't registered then they can pay dirt
cheap have you seen that video from the
DSA meeting where the guy stands up and
he's like a point of personal privilege
my name is you know John Smith he him
can I just let everybody know that you
know the chatter is really giving me
anxiety so can we keep the chatter to a
minimum and then he's like guys please
and then all sudden
huffing and puffing gets up and goes do
not use gendered language you've not
seen this no oh man well you've seen it
yeah I think most people have seen it
but the reason I bring this up and if
you haven't seen it seriously look up
the viral video from the Democratic
socialists you look at how these people
behave and I think it's fair to say
something they're not they're not all
there yeah I'm not trying to be mean you
know I'm not saying this to like get an
emotional reaction on somebody but
they're clearly not with it yeah what do
you think that happens if you go to them
and say we should have no borders right
they're gonna be like yes and then
you're simultaneous are gonna say but
we're working for the for the labor
unions right yes yeah that's right get
people who are too dumb to recognize
their contradictory ideas yeah so that's
what I don't get about Bernie Sanders or
know what any of it means right right
but they'll stand up and say you know
John Smith he/him/his it's like thanks I
guess whatever sure we'll keep the
chatter down but it was it's it's it's
really yeah but then they don't there's
really funny they don't keep it down
yeah and then there's another like a
there's another clip where he gets up
but he sucks yelling again I'm already
sad keep the chatter to the minimum it
is triggering to my anxiety yeah they're
like it's it's it's like toddlers in
adult bodies yep
I see it all over the place so so so now
we have but basically an end to these
policies is it the craziest thing to me
I don't understand why there's so many
conservatives trying to downplay what's
going on or act like it's not happening
it's like Trump is getting what he wants
yeah it's like oh there was a new report
that came out saying factories are
coming back yeah that's it boom good
it's like a guillotine dropped and just
sliced it in half gotta come back all
these people in the chats were like is
is that him is that I'm talking I mean I
was dude I mean there is something to be
said about them having all of the
factories all of our medicine is made
over there if I was made here we would
be stronger wouldn't we this is we would
it's a simple truth this is the weird
politics that's happening right now yeah
Bernie Sanders I was a big fan of him
back in like 2015 and 16 you know why
you know Bernie Sanders was saying we
need border security yeah
we need to fight for the working class
he was talking about national populist
positions that spoke to a lot of
Americans you know and I'm like these
guys right he was asked about Second
Amendment urban versus rural debate and
I was like wow yeah that's the that's
that's that's legit man that's it I've
seen it and then all of a sudden he
starts getting closer and closer and was
he do I don't know man that million
dollars looks pretty good
that fourth house mmm that looks pretty
good he's only got three he's only got
three I'm just kidding I only have three
oh come on dude that dude flipped so
quick and now and now that's like the
big thing right now that what the the
true progressives are like no Bernie
we're not gonna get behind you yeah but
that's what's crazy a lot of people
don't seem to get it I disagreed a lot
with Bernie's policies unlike he put out
something that said that they were gonna
pay for college by putting a tax on
speculation on Wall Street and so I
remember I was hanging out by 30 rock
and there were some progressives they
were talking about it and they said that
they supported him because he was gonna
you know free college and all that and I
was like yeah but how do you how do you
pay for that yeah like because you got
to realize if you promise free college
then you've you've now got basically
every single person eligible to go which
means the schools will fill up and then
no one can go right any more schools all
right you need bigger schools you need
more professors that's a lot of money
you can't you can't predict right but
let's say you you do you do say it costs
you know 75 trillion or some ridiculous
number where does it come from and it's
progressive guy was like we're gonna tax
Wall Street and I was like I don't I
don't know if that means I think what
this what do you what do you tax like
and does he even know what that means he
did not exactly and so I asked him it's
such a fluff piece it means nothing I
was like what do you what do you mean by
like taxing Wall Street and he was like
you know like like stocks and stuff like
they make all that money and I was like
do you know what most of those stocks
are and like where that money goes
it's like people's 401ks and stuff it's
not like you know their day traders
their speculation but most of what you
see in like Wall Street trading is like
pensions or something I don't know I
don't know it works and I was like but
it's not like you're assuming there's
some like rich dude in like a pinstripe
suit smoking a cigar yeah yeah that's
all riding on the wall
right that was Commission's and stuff
right and then he's progression sorry
getting mad saying like would you renew
your notes Wall Street man they're
making all this money and I was like
dude do you even understand how trade
volume works like if you put in a dome
yeah if you put a tax on a product you
increase the cost of the transaction
people might not make your transaction
you might make any money at all so look
anyway the point is there are things
about Bernie says I completely disagreed
with but there are a lot of points he
made and that's why so many people
switched from Bernie to Trump that's why
the PAS gonna do it again you know
although now Bernie has tried to adopt
like dude a year ago he was saying what
was he saying like there's too many poor
people in the world we can't have open
borders where does he where does he go
in the last debate last month he
criminalized open to criminalize the
border crossings amnesty jobs it's like
you have completely abandoned everything
aspiration this is what bugs me out
because it's like I was saying about the
DSA and all that they their positions
are completely contradictory Bernie did
an interview with the New York Times and
they said you know 2015 you said illegal
immigration reduces low-skill wages and
he was like yes it absolutely does and
they're like so you admit it and then
all of a sudden he got flack from the
left again he had they're like no Bernie
you're wrong it doesn't it does we know
it does this is what people need to
realize about Bernie Sanders he's not
consistent yeah it's not like a lot of
people do that meme no refunds and he's
supposed to be the consistent one right
the one again speaking the same thing
for he knows consistent a long time
until he got the major platform that he
now has hold the book and now he's
changed
he no longer says the million is now you
says the billion is yeah he's in the
club in the club there's a big club you
ain't in it
Trump's been pretty consistent I mean I
gotta admit Trump says stupid things a
lot like the most recent thing he said
about having absolute power now there's
no excuse for that or like I can reopen
the states like now you can't do it
again I'm sorry yeah but look I you know
the media screen' screeches in his face
all day every day and it's like I get it
man I get it okay all right people want
to vote for the guy than vote for the
guy what bothers me is people coming out
acting like Bernie Sanders isn't in a
similar position with his lying in his
flip-flopping they're like he's
consistent I'm like no he's not
you know nobody says it but Trump's been
talking about China and all this stuff
for a really long time his positions
been pretty pretty straightforward yeah
but but the main point I want to bring
up is people are saying you're talking
Mogga I'm like no I mean yes technically
but Trump is a moderate yeah and and
even vaak I'm quoting Vox here the
left-wing progressive site so he runs
and says I would do these basic things
the Democrats used to campaign on I
think what happened was Trump comes out
as a Republican but offers up a moderate
Democrat kind of position without the
elitism in this in the you know ivory
tower kind of kind of behaviors you end
up with a guy who was saying secure our
borders America first repair our economy
bring back our jobs protect the unions
and I'm like that sounds like a union
are you a union worker you know get
their positions on how the government
should be run or like a Democrat from
the 90s yeah I mean but even then you
still a deal lead it the elitists is
ivory tower Democrats like you look at
these Union guys when the guy who
confronted Biden on the ar-15 mm-hmm
like that these are Union Democrat dudes
yeah and they're like why do you want to
take away my right to bear arms or
whatever yeah and Donald Trump says I
won't and all sudden you end up with a
moderate guy Trump was pretty
I don't throw I would describe it is but
pretty let's say fierce on key issues
yeah one of the things I think was a
stupidest thing ever said was that
Donald Trump was calling for a complete
and total ban on Muslims entering the
country or whatever it's like a
statement from his campaign I went back
and I watched it he said some things
that were absolutely worthy of criticism
but I think what happened was if you
come out if you're if you're Donald
Trump and you make yourself the villain
but then say something like I want to
secure the border the Democrats that had
no choice but to reject anything he ever
proposed which makes them seem insane
it's it's almost like you know bizarro
Superman yeah like so there's Superman
and he's all like evil Superman he's not
evil so right regular Superman is all
like charming and chiseled and handsome
okay
bizarro is like underbite really dumb
and he's like reverse Superman okay yeah
it's like so he's like he's not
necessarily evil but everything's
backwards okay so he speaks in like
opposites that's what the Democrats have
been doing it's like you're sort of
Seinfeld where George Costanza is like
today I'm gonna do everything the
opposite of what I
normally do I have seen it but I don't
remember it's all it's basically the
Democrats have been doing their like
they're holding up a list of things
Trump said he's four and they must
oppose so they end up being opposed to
ridiculous things yeah yeah anyway we
somebody was that actually do make sense
yeah right you should to be like you
know what that's that's actually a good
idea
okay so seed so is Adam talking Mogga no
no I'm not talking my god I'm talking
mog mog ma ji make America great period
well yeah or greater greater yeah make
America not greater mug I think is the
best way to put it because we are great
and we could be better let's be better
but the the narrative on the left is
that America was never great that's
literally what they say we're so spoiled
whoever saying out there they're spoiled
and they have no idea and that that
frustrates me man
yeah they have no idea how great America
actually is so you know travel the world
and and then come back and and tell a
goat not travel Europe not not Europe go
go to like Morocco yeah go to go to like
the China like I was in South Africa
right and I landed in Cape Town
beautiful place but then I had to travel
for like an hour and a half outside and
as soon as you get outside there's no
green grass anymore you know it's like
the favelas of Brazil right it's the
same you know shaggy towns yeah they
have to walk for water and it's like you
have no idea how great America is this
place is amazing unless we can make it
better
you know what China is doing right now
what are the Nick Donald's yes what is
up with this now tell tell people a
little bit what you heard
alright well man China is crazy man
they're they're now basically saying
black people are spreading the virus
more than others and McDonald's is now
saying you're not allowed in if you're
black do you have any so messed up do
you have any idea what would happen to
McDonald's if they did that in this
country
goodbye McDonald's I mean I haven't
eaten there and forever but it's
ridiculous yeah I wouldn't want that is
so messed up if McDonald's handed out
flyers banning people based on race yeah
first their stock price would drop by
like 50 percent in
as soon as the news broke everyone would
sell all their stock mm-hmm I'm premise
um I'm assuming they're publicly traded
on whatever then all of a sudden the
federal government would immediately
step in and issue a bunch of fines you
know they would be shut down in minutes
Donald's would disappear totally yeah
disappear and and I mean if they didn't
corporate right Lisa if at a corporate
level they did it right now I doubt it
was at a corporate level it was probably
like I mean no no that governmental
'evil so that yeah the Chinese
government made them all do it right
dude man the CCP virus yo that's it
Americans man we got we got too many
virus we got too many spoiled people to
place the broke the blame where it
belongs
man I wonder if like how do you restore
that worldliness to some of these people
it's no surprise that a lot of these
people who are saying America was never
great our city folk yeah you know you
know it's a city folk or even even more
spoiled I was thinking about this when I
lived in New York I'm like I'm like
standing out front of my apartment I'm
like they're a sidewalk under my feet
yep there's a park in front of my
apartment there's a water fountain with
fresh running water all of these things
have always been here yep
and not only that I can have any kind of
food I want to my doorstep by with a nap
in 30 minutes press a button boop Moe
said most people in cities their their
way out I got I got one more for you
Gohan not only can I have any food
delivered to my doorstep in New York
City I can press a button and get
Venezuelan or Epis delivered to my
apartment while people in Venezuela are
starving and can't even eat that food we
have access to food from countries that
can't even make the same food themselves
but but here's the piers the Pillai was
making about this I'm looking at all
these things that are just there I
remember I was crossing the Williamsburg
Bridge and I'm like man look at this
massive bridge had to cost the
equivalent of like a billion dollars to
make it's just there you know you never
have to think twice about all the
back-breaking labor that went into
making that so what do you think's gonna
happen then if you grow up in a city
where this is your baseline where
everything's just been handed to you
yeah now compare that to going out in
the middle of nowhere maybe in the
middle of what you know Wyoming or
Montana and you're like we're gonna live
here is there any water nope
start digging you got a pump yup
you need to go to the store 30 miles
dude I was driving through Wyoming yeah
and we had I defaulting a gas we like
sabe got gas
I was driving my friend we drove for
hundreds of miles not seeing a gas
station I thought we were known at a gas
and I'm like well that's it there's like
nothing here we're out of gas
I guess we live here now yep this is
life it's nothing for hundreds of miles
yeah and then there was this little tiny
shop with two gas pumps and I did not
even realize there's a gas station till
my friend was like look pumps and I was
like whoa and sure enough I was like
able to get gas and keep going people
it's it's you you can you live in these
cities and that massive infrastructure
is just there yep there's it is there
standing on the shoulders of giants that
they can't see boom that's a you know a
lot of this see what's the problem with
him make America great again is I wasn't
alive when it was supposedly great in
what he was talking about back in like
what was it like the 30s regular fifties
the sixties like I was born in the 80s
you know this is the life I know and
this is a good life that we have you
know man you know I think it is I think
it's just have you actually had to work
I mean yeah there's times there I had a
buck alone work now right I mean I'm
have you gone through true hardship I've
you have you seen what it's like to not
be able to survive have you had a loved
ones you know suffer and struggle and
yep
I know that exactly many times and a lot
of these a lot of these people so we see
this in the data these these progressive
activists tend to be college educated
making more than $100,000 a year yeah
and then and they're mostly white you
know so it's really funny that they
embody exactly what they complain about
but that makes sense
think about it you're the super wealthy
privileged not a chance a super wealthy
but you're an upper-class privileged
young White's you know low tea soy boy
or whatever and you're looking around at
all these wonderful things you have and
then you hear these stories about how
bad things are and you're like I blame
people like me and the assumption they
make is that every other white person
must be just like them right instead of
realizing 20 million poor people white
in this country right they assume it's
you know everyone must be like me they
must have the same experience as I do
of doing nothing for everything that's
the other problem with college too is
that you know that one of the reasons I
see them they they end up going to
college a lot of these people end up
becoming permanent students because they
don't want to take any responsibility
they're scared of it I know some people
like that totally yep I know people who
are like they're my age and they they
made the thirties right out of high
school and they're still in school don't
got to pay back those loans as long as
you're in school and then you what they
do they vote for Bernie to forgive their
you know hundreds of thousand dollars in
loans yeah they they took all this money
lived for free refused to do any work
and that was it now it's like you pay
for it I guess it's just uh I I don't
know what we do to solve that problem of
them being spoiled hard times hard times
it's the only way you know Rama Rama
Manuel when he got elected in Chicago
said something about mandatory basic
training and I really do not like that
idea at all for a Liberty I don't even
sorry anything right
yeah don't force me to do anything but
but I wonder if there is a better way to
implement some kind of retreat or
something you can do in school an ROTC
class it's one semester you know you're
not you're not in boot camp but yeah
they're teaching the I don't like high
school mandatory either well I mean it's
like I don't know make it a part of gym
class I get what you're saying yeah you
know it's like I don't want to be told
how to live my life but at the same time
you know if I structured my life better
I could probably get more things done
maybe there's an I do you know I could
have a game game podcast going people
are asking me to do it but I you know I
don't really structure my life in a way
that I can just do that all the time I
don't think that's as much an issue
though like you not yes bring my own
into it but I'm saying like these are
people who think they don't recognize
the wealth and privilege they have and
it's a funny thing they stay like they
like to say that's my point they like to
say that you know to the to the to the
privileged equality looks like
oppression and I'm like have you looked
in a mirror good sir because you're
describing yourself not me
right when you complain you know that
they as part of their philosophy they
literally believe that a black woman
who's a millionaire
is oppressed and a white person who's
sleeping on the street is an oppressor
it's actually a part of like the
arguments have been made and you know
it's funny because when I tried talking
to some of the more rational
progressives they're like no one really
thinks that I'm like dude do you even
listen to the the priests of your
religion they say this stuff all the
time yeah I get it
there are progressives who don't you
know entertain these the silliness but
they ignore the rest of them that aren't
actually pushing the stuff they have
fringe ideas that make no sense and you
know what's funny is like we talked
about how as things get bad they kind of
disappear yeah well they're starting to
come back because things are getting
better things you didn't but we'll see
we'll see how it plays out but you're
right yeah it's it's how do you make
people not spoiled anymore that's the
big challenge you can't I don't believe
it I don't I do not like the I do not
like any manager I don't like that you
have to go to high school I don't like
that you have to go to school period
I think that's stupid I think a
one-size-fits-all government mandate for
institutionalization of human beings is
insane you got a point what do you do
got a good point what do you do man yeah
I mean you know you're Lydia was just
like hard times and it's like right that
the saying is hard times make strong men
or something like a mandatory program I
was thinking of the way we've been so
privileged is going to cause hard times
that we have no say in right so how do
we how do we get get to the skip that
you know like to skip like can we wake
up before it's too late and we're all in
hard times and we're realizing that
America was really great there's
anything can do you know I I've been
around the world man I I the more I
traveled the more I would come back
proud to be an American yeah and I were
I would remember like coming up to the
the you know the the checkpoint after
being in some like really messed up
place yeah and then I remember like one
guy was like looking at my passport and
I got a ton of crazy stuff like Arabic
and whatever and he's like he's like man
what is this he's like what what's this
country and I was like I think that's
like Morocco or Egypt or something and
he was like you travel a lot what for
and I was like I'm a journalist and he
goes hmm
how is it and I'm like man I am so glad
to be back it's like you you these young
people who complain about America all
day night they
don't get it when you get locked into
camp in China and they take your organs
away when they kick out you and/or your
friends because of the color of their
skin when you go to these countries
where they're speeding down streets
afraid to stop at streetlights because
someone's gonna jump out with an aka or
something yeah and it's like man I've
been I've and I haven't even been of the
worst places in the world you know I
haven't been to like Siri or anything
yeah I did have some people try to get
me to go but even I'm like dude I know
how bad it gets yeah and I know people
have gone in these places I mean I was
in Fukushima so that's probably the one
of the craziest places have a place I've
ever been
and I saw the destroyed gravestones I'll
tell you what man I went there the
gravestones shattered and this guy
telling us like this was his family's
you know grave and like it's been
destroyed and it's like the earthquake
destroyed it going to this guy's house
the calendar left at the day of the
earthquake and the tsunami the clocks
all stopped at that time and you realize
like everything this guy's family was
everything he ever had everything he
ever cherished and loved wiped out in an
instant and he can only come back and
take a glimpse of it and I'll tell you
what's even crazier the the guides we
had that brought us in one of them died
of cancer Wow that's the radiation
that's how some people are deal what
they're dealing with right now but in
America we got poverty we got crime we
got bad stuff yeah but they really don't
get how bad things could be thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you